ihn lieben sie hier Vladimir Putin hat
in Malis Hauptstadt barmaco viele
Freunde überall Zeichen der
Verbundenheit zu Russland die russischen
Fahnen flattern fröhlich neben denen
Malis wer die Freundschaft zu Russland
offen in Zweifel zieht hat allerdings
ein Problem Sowi kadicia Fofana die
38-Jährige ist Geschäftsführerin von
Radio gundo einem kleinen Internetsender
in barmaco eigentlich arbeitet im
Außenministerium doch ihre Meinung war
dort nicht gefragt sie wurde
entlassen wir müssen verstehen dass wir
uns nicht auf einen Partner begrenzen
können wir müssen mit jedem
zusammenarbeiten kein Land kann es sich
mehr leisten isoliert zu
sein wir müssen offen sein mit anderen
zu verhandeln und gleichzeitig stark
sein in Fragen der
Souveränität beiadi wollen sie
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer miteinander ins
Gespräch bringen ein mühsames Geschäft
denn deren Meinung so sagt Moderator
Kalifa ber steht eigentlich schon fest
wenn der Strom ausfällt oder der Reis
teurer wird es sei Schuld des Westens
diskutieren will hier keiner
mehr der größte Teil der Bevölkerung
gerade die jungen wollen mit den Russen
zusammenarbeiten weil sie sie für
aufrichtig halten das ist die Realität
selst wen man denen gib offen zu
sprechen sagen sie das sie sprechen von
einer WINWIN Partnerschaft mit
Russland vor gut Z Jahren putschte sich
in Mali das Militär unter assimi an die
Macht das Land verlässt der
Interimspräsident nur noch für die
wichtigsten Termine aus Angst selbst aus
dem Amt gejagt zu werden vertraute Fotos
beim russlandafrika Gipfel an der Seite
von Vladimir Putin aber helfen ihm in
der Heimat dasut die einst versprochenen
demokratischen Wahlen immer Wied absagt
finden Sie hier auf barmakus
traditionellen Markt richtig das Land
sei im Krieg mit den Islamisten nun sei
für Wahlen nicht der richtige
Zeitpunkt ich denke dass die
übergangsbehörden den Kampf gegen den
Terrorismus fortsetzen sollten sobald
sie das ganze Chaos in unserem Land
beseitigt haben können wir Wahlen
abhalten und wenn es zu Wahlen kommt
möchte ich dass unser Präsident assim
goita kandidiert und wir werden für ihn
stimmen
das Chaos im Land das meint vor allem
den Kampf gegen islamistische Gruppen im
Norden und Osten des Landes Anflug auf
Gau dort wo nur noch bis Ende des Jahres
auch die Bundeswehr im Einsatz ist ihr
Abzug eine politische Entscheidung Malis
Regierung wollte keine UN-Truppen mehr
den Flughafen von Gao nutzen noch die UN
aber auch die russischen Wagner Söldner
und malische Streitkräfte alle belauern
sich
gegenseitig in unmittelbarer Sichtweite
des deutschen Camps Castor explodierten
vor knapp drei Wochen Bomben
islamistische Selbstmordattentäter waren
ins malische Lager eingedrungen den
ganzen Tag gab es
Kämpfe der deutsche Hauptfeldwebel
sebastian hatte gerade
Dienst es ist hier grundsätzlich so dass
es lange ruhig ist und dann mal wieder
ein Zeichen gesetzt wird heißt
grundsätzlich rechnet man damit vor
allem wenn man das Land kennt
aber für uns wir waren er 17 Tage im
Land dementsprechend dass so schnell
wieder was passiert hätte keiner von uns
gedacht die deutschen können nur zusehen
eingreifen dürfen sie nicht das sieh der
un-aftrag minusma nicht vor vielleicht
hat sich die malische Militärregierung
auch deshalb die russischen Partner ins
Land geholt ob sie sich den richtigen
Partner ausgesucht haben die haben sich
den ausgesucht weil sie einen suchten
der IH bei counterterrorism hilft
während minusma einen anderen Auftrag
hatte der Auftrag der Bundeswehr die
Aufklärung zu Luft und am Boden ist
beendet und ihr Abzug beschlossene Sache
die Zahl der blutigen Anschläge in der
Region hat seitdem wieder zugenommen in
timbukdtu etwa wurden unlängst beim
Angriff von Jihadisten auf ein fchiff
mehr als 60 Zivilisten und Soldaten
getötet es gab
Staatstrauer jetzt gehen die ganzen
minusmakräfte das wird man hier schon
spüren glaube ich und die
Zivilbevölkerung auf jeden Fall das
Militär lässt uns im Grunde auch wissen
dass sie es eigentlich schade finden
dass wir gehen doch der weit weg vom
politischen barmak die Stimmung aber
ändert sich auch hier noch vor einem
Jahr herrschte Euphorie auf dem Platz
der Unabhängigkeit viele derer die
damals die militärunter feierten sind
inzwischen im Gefängnis weil sie Wahlen
lautstark einfordern Basar Silla
unterstützt die russlandfreundliche
Bewegung jerevolo die war zunächst auf
der Seite der Putschisten jetzt aber
traut sie ihn nicht
mehr wenn derzige Präsident vom Volk
gewählt wird ist das Demokratie glauben
dass Demokratie die Kraft der Menschen
ist und die Menschen zeigen heutzutage
wen sie lieben also sollten wir die
Dinge richtig machen wir organisieren
Wahlen dann kann auch eher demokratisch
gewählt werden das würde doch die Dinge
vereinfachen auch jevolo will eine enge
Partnerschaft mit Russland gleichzeitig
aber pocht sie auf malische Souveränität
und will sich keinen Illusionen über die
Interessen Putins
hingeben
Mali nicht unterstützen nur weil es mali
ist und der Mitleid hat nein Putin hat
eigene Interessen wir sind reif genug um
das zu verstehen Mali hat auch
Interessen an Putin wir brauchen die
Waffen die neuen Technologien wir kaufen
Sie Ihnen ab das ist alles das ist
einfach Geopolitik
Ende des Jahres ziehen die UN-Truppen
aus Mali ab das Land setzt dann voll auf
Russland ob dem letzten Putsch der
nächste folgt Skeptiker fürchten das und
auch dass in subsahara Afrika die Zeiten
noch unruhiger
werden